foreign
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS moving and storage Studios
it's the Ramsay show where Dad is dumb
cash is king and the paid off Home
Mortgage has taken the place of the BMW
as the status symbol of choice
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships we're glad you're with us
America Christina Alice number one
best-selling author Ramsey personality
is my co-host today as we talk to you
about your life and your money the phone
numbers are easy and the call is free
some say the advice is worth exactly
what you pay for it the phone number is
888-825-5225-88-825-5225 Matthew is with
us in Los Angeles hi Matthew welcome to
the Ramsey Show
Hi how are you doing better than I
deserve what's up in your world
we'll have a couple of quick questions
um first of all
um I have a annuity flash 401k plan
um and there's about close to a million
dollars in there and I got this letter
from the organization and they have this
program and it's called a single life
annuity and is I'll read it to you it
says that pays you a fixed amount of
money each month for the rest of your
life
and then it says following your death no
payments will be made to your spouse of
your heirs so the estimated payment that
they'll pay me under that condition is
forty three hundred dollars a month but
I also offer
that sucks
right 48 000 on a million dollars 4.8
percent return on your million dollars
and then you lose all your money at
death
well this is the thing um I I I don't
know if I you misunderstood they're
going to pay me yes they're going to pay
me 4 300 a month yeah forty eight
thousand dollars a year okay
that's correct yeah you do quick math
okay okay but they also but they also
offer that for a lesser amount which
will be 3 600 a month that
um I can uh my spouse will be able to
continue at that amount that's so sweet
of her life that's so sweet so they're
going to screw you again yeah no all
right no no no no no no and no and no
and no no no this is a million dollar
mistake
okay so have you got a fireplace have
you got a fireplace by chance uh I do
yeah okay good you can use this letter
for kenneling
okay well see the thing is is that and
that's kind of my question is you're
always concerned on how long you're
going to live now I mean
um is I mean I'm concerned that you're a
million dollars poorer
when you die after only getting a 4.8
return on your money
okay that concerns me
when you could have been in good mutual
funds averaging a 10 rate of return and
when you die the million dollars is
still there
right right right oh so this is like a
well it's like you're you're accepting
half the money you should be getting per
month and you lose all of your money at
retirement and they wink and Nod and act
like they're doing you a favor
this is laughable I I think the reason
that they bring this forward is because
a lot of folks don't like to have to
deal with you know
the reason they bring It Forward is
anybody that's dumb enough to do it
they're screwing them out of a million
dollars that's the reason they bring It
Forward
it is not well they they present it as
as being convenient for you yeah well
yeah yeah you have a guarantee you're
guaranteed to be screwed
yeah okay I mean seriously well if you
can let listen I mean if you the stock
market is averaged 11.8 since it began
right if it does half
of what it is averaged
for the next 20 years
you are still going to have more money
per month and then leave your heirs a
million dollars
more than these goobers are offering you
you understand the difference
they can swing at death
yeah well
well still you know it's not taxed yet I
mean you know I've pulled it out so I
mean it's you know I do know that and I
do know that your income is going to be
taxed as you pull it off per the income
but I wasn't even going to touch the
million I was going to live off of the
return it created and it just sits there
right
and guess what it's not taxed yeah so
there you go yeah that no no no no no
when a life insurance company says we
are here to help you in general it's
like the government saying we are here
to help you in both cases you should
scream set your hair on fire and run out
of the room
right yeah and I think
after I think a lot of people feel
overwhelmed and they're like we'll take
care of you don't worry about you know
you could live 30 more years and we'll
make sure you're taken care of but it's
not really the reality of the situation
they're not there to to be super
generous to you another way of looking
at Matthew is is you wouldn't have a
million dollars
if you have been using their products to
grow your wealth
you wouldn't even have this problem the
fact that you were self-sufficient
well and it's like if you want to have
that convenience factor if you are
feeling a little bit overwhelmed with
your finances and you have savings then
talk to a Smart Master Pro I mean that's
someone who can take that overwhelm and
guide you into to things that are really
going to grow your money and help you in
the long run
being broke is always inconvenient
having half the money you should have is
inconvenient that's inconvenience so uh
no don't don't look for a babysitter
um don't look for a magic wand manage
your money make your money behave live
off of the income
I mean a million dollars creating a 10
rate of return is a hundred thousand
dollars a year not fifty thousand
dollars a year yeah well and just the
fees on these products are ridiculous I
was just talking with my in-laws about
this over Thanksgiving and they were
talking about annuities and showing me
some of the paperwork and it's like whoo
that is ridiculous even if there is a
death benefit it is not great yeah yeah
and it's just um so the best thing to do
is to run from these people as fast as
you possibly can do your investing in
good Investments and good Investments
are never found at life insurance
companies
do not go to the transmission store to
fix your muffler
they work on Transmissions life
insurance people should be in the Life
Insurance business they got in the
investment business because they figured
out it was a way to screw people and
that's what this is anytime you pay
someone half of what they should be
getting per month and then you keep
their money when they die that by
definition is screwing them
and so if you don't like it and you're
in that business you should get in
another business and that way I won't
say you're screwing people like Dave
Ramsey Dave Ramsey said you're a crook
okay that's what Dave Ramsey just said I
stand up for the consumer I don't give a
flip what you think if you work for a
life insurance company you can just
pound sand right and so that was nice I
cleaned that up considerable but the um
no seriously um I I you know there's
there's entire websites devoted from the
life insurance world that hate on Dave
Ramsey and I am
blessed by that fact because that means
that I'm standing up for the consumer
instead of you out there you listeners
uh and because I am not taking a poll
with those morons oh my gosh no really
seriously go handle your own money
you'll have more money during life
you'll have more money during death ride
the roller coaster yourself they're
riding it and keeping the change while
you sit there and take the uh the lint
out of your pocket and that's all you
get this is the Ramsay shop
[Music]
foreign
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
well if you didn't know today is giving
Tuesday
I guess that follows Black Friday and
Cyber Monday who knew it's a day
completely dedicated to giving with
outrageous generosity I thought that was
Christmas and if you've taken Financial
Peace University you know that giving is
the most fun you can have with money we
teach that all the time and what I'm
telling you is there's nothing more fun
than giving someone else a taste of the
peace that you've discovered and you
could do that with the money because
it'll change their life and it'll change
their family's lives so for today only
we are offering an incredible deal on
Financial Peace University
by 2 Financial Peace University
memberships
for only
99.99 that's sixty dollars off the
regular price so if you want one and you
give one you got the deal of deals on
this serious serious bargain uh one of
the best prices we have ever offered and
we're also extending our Black Friday
offer to get our lowest price ever on a
single if you want to do that but both
of these deals end today at the end of
giving Tuesday so give them as Christmas
gifts bless somebody in your church or
your office get the course in the hands
of people who need it uh it's what
Financial Peace is all about living and
giving like no one else so to buy FPU as
a gift go to ramseysolutions.com
give FPU
ramseysolutions.com
Christina Alice Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Dennis is with us in New York
City hi Dennis how are you
hi Dave and Christina uh how you guys
doing better than we deserve what's up
um I was just wondering uh I haven't
heard you talk about it I don't think
um my pension allows me to retire at 55.
and so I've led up on I believe it's
called The Law of 55 that you can you
can pull from a 401k if you retire right
yeah there's a calculation there's a
calculation that you can it's a very
small amount once you run the formula
without being penalized uh and it's it's
really pretty minuscule so if you don't
have like a massive 401K it's not going
to mount anything
oh okay I didn't know there was a
restriction on the amount oh it
definitely is yeah now the exception is
there are a few special 401 cases
special Industries special companies
that are structured in such a way that
at 55 it's available but 99 of them uh
including mine are available only after
59 and a half
in your 401k
or 340 I think
yeah okay yeah I mean I've got another
17 years to retire but you know so what
are you going to do
just go do something else I
well I'll have a pension for my company
yeah
um so I mean you're 55 years old what
are you gonna do sit on your butt for 40
years yeah of course yeah find something
to fill the time yeah like go make more
than you used to make doing something
you love
probably yeah okay what do you make now
uh 150 this year so far what do you do
I work for the utility company okay
there's electric and gas and stuff but
listen I I so what I'm challenging is
this premise that life is better when
you don't have work
I kind of think life is better when you
do have work
you know the number of people that die
like two years after they retire because
they sit around have nothing to do and
they just die it's crazy I mean it's um
so there's a purpose now if you hate
what you're doing and you want to move
to a different chapter fine but I've had
friends for instance I had a friend of
mine that sold his business out when he
was 32 went bass fishing for three years
got fat
and um caught a bunch of fish and got
fat and got bored and went back into
business at 36 and he was worth 10
million dollars but he was just bored
out of his gourd he said the bass
fishing I thought that was going to be
the end I thought the rest of my life I
get to do whatever I'm gonna play golf
and bass fish that's all I'm gonna do
and he said it was absolutely the most
empty life I've ever had he says I
wanted to do something and move
something around and contribute and I
think you'll find that you find more
happiness doing that that's my challenge
now I'm not saying you don't necessarily
leave this job or this career but I
would what we call it in our world is an
encore career after the play is over you
take a bow and you come out
and you do or after the concert's over
you come out and you do an encore you
play another song right and sometimes
the song After the bow after the
standing ovation is the best one you
ever seen and so it's not unusual at all
for someone 55 to make the most money
they've ever made in their life doing
something they love when they left the
job that got them that far and take a
bow yeah Dennis I would challenge you to
create a vision for what this next
season of life is going to look like and
if you want to take six months or a year
you know to bass fish hopefully you
don't get a little chunky like Dave's
friend but you know take some time to do
something fun
um that's great but then think through
what do you want to do after that I mean
what does that look like that Encore
career or maybe it's non-profit service
maybe there's something else you're
passionate about but create that Vision
before you leave your job so that you're
really motivated moving forward and
let's get him a copy of paycheck to
purpose absolutely so that he can you
know kind of work through what does that
next career look like that's going to
light you on fire let's do it I'm in
just do something I mean you don't have
to be stressed out and I'm saying I'm
just saying you just life is more fun
when you're contributing rather than
just uh coasting and you're going to
find that pretty quick Bernard is in
California hey Bernard how are you
how you doing Dave better than I deserve
how can we help
yes
um I was I'm in a dilemma uh sort of
saying
um it's been reached at uh it looks like
we're my wife and I were gonna enter
into the world of divorce and I you know
I I bought a house just recently haven't
even been a year yet
and uh we had this agreement on how we
should raise our 19 year old daughter in
uh the 19 year old daughter won and
we've been at odds ever since the 26th
of September and so I have a brand new
house and if I initiate the divorce
process
I as the guy has to leave the house who
said you know well the attorneys who
I've you know basically trying to see
where my footing was and he said that I
have to leave the house to check there's
not a judge in the world that's going to
put 11 year old child in the street and
uh I cannot leave a house and go and pay
rent some place and still pay the
mortgage so I was going to have a
meeting today with my family and tell
them look I can't afford to file and
can't afford to leave the house so uh
I'm gonna have to stay here and cash
this out now I'm this I'm the soul
Breadwinner here in the house okay so
how does she expect to live
after she divorces you or causes you to
file divorce
well she's listening to some more
armchair lawyer and uh she is saying
that she's not leaving anywhere and
there she has a divorce that wasn't what
I asked
okay if she doesn't have a job
and you can't pay rent and a house
payment how does she think
that she's going to be able to live
without your income because you're going
to pay child support
and maybe some alimony but it's not
going to be enough to support that house
and that household
yes you feel that I have to some kind of
way go get another job no that's not
what the law says not even in weird
California
I understand but before that I have a
hard time where it is if if I file
I'm the one that's going to have to
leave the house so don't follow the
attorney yeah so don't file
that's what I was breaking an incident
today about when everybody get out of
school who's them to let them know for
my my 11 year old you don't need to
negotiate with an 11 year old
I appreciate this but she's very
boisterous I couldn't have a crap last
she's 11. I got you today she's the
biggest Saver in the house
yes and therein we have your problem sir
I think you need to become the biggest
in the house again the inmates are
running the asylum
there's your issue but no dude I mean
money doesn't just suddenly start
appearing in her pocket or your pocket
because we can't get along and your
income doubles and she can magically
live the life she's been living this
house will be sold and she will be
getting a job and the 11 year old will
be in freaking daycare
this is what's going to happen so
everybody needs to get their heads
around what this is going to cause when
we're all here and then maybe we can
decide who's really making decisions
there
foreign
[Music]
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess with health care costs
Rising learn how Christian Healthcare
Ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org budget don't worry it
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America this is the Ramsey Show in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the that
free stage Amar and Jennifer are with us
hey guys how are you hey how are you
guys better than we deserve where do you
guys live we we're from Orlando Florida
oh very good well good to have you thank
you for having us very cool so how much
debt have you paid off we paid off a
hundred and three thousand dollars all
right how long did this take 18 months
wow and your range of income during that
time it was 77 000 to 125. very cool
very cool so what kind of debt was the
one hundred and three thousand
um majorly was my student loans
um taxes credit cards and Consumer Debt
oh you kind of just had everything
yeah very good all right how long you
guys been married two years we just uh
celebrate our two year anniversary on
the 20th of November ah very good yes
very good well it's an honor to have you
all today congratulations thank you
thank you you're so happy to be here
right after you get married you go game
on we're clean this mess up tell me the
story yes well I mean once we got
married
um
long story short yes we've been living
the normal lives stuff that you don't
know you know we were ignorant about our
finances we didn't know uh how to manage
our money you know none of that stuff so
we were obviously leaving paycheck to
page you know we have plenty plenty of
stories I have one of them for example
uh that I always mentioned to people
that now I talk about finances is that I
ate the most expensive cookie I've ever
had
from a gas station why was that because
I paid 150 for the cookie and then the
overdraft kicked in so it was like 37
dollars
37 cookies
Gourmet gas station cookies not even he
was super dry now the free one that you
have here they're a lot better for so
many reasons exactly so I love it yeah
so I mean it was it was all the norm you
know we didn't know so you can you don't
do what you don't know you know so yeah
so after we got married in 2020 of
November
um we did the typical couple thing we
wanted to buy a house so we met up with
his brother who's a realtor and A lender
and um we pretty much asked they asked
us the questions like what's your dad
what's your income what's your credit
score and every question that they asked
us were just like oh my God we are so in
over our heads there's no possible way
we can afford a house right now and
that's what kind of kicked us into gear
yeah we're like okay this is not gonna
happen it's like when you go to the
doctor and you want to tell him what you
do
you do this
um yes you know so you know you know
you're going to be sick right so um yeah
so that happened yeah so after that uh
we got I mean we got your book uh we'll
get into that in a second uh I read the
book I was telling uh Jennifer AKA bubu
that's the name I gave his boo-boo
um and I told her this is what we got to
do you know because if we do not make a
change it's not going to happen you know
and it was the it was like if it was in
a boxing match with the book
re-read you know it was a jab to the
face
jab to the face you know Ramsay with
that with the boxing gloves
and it was definitely definitely a
mindset uh change it has to be it has to
start with you and until that happens uh
it's not it's Nothing's Gonna Change you
know it's like what you guys say if
nothing changed nothing changes right so
we had to do something you know so we
got really really got cell intense after
that we started knocking down uh small
debts I feel like I feel like the first
80 to 100 pages of the book is all about
mindset you know uh behavior and that's
the main thing that we got on to you
know um started paying off the debts
with the debt snowball
all the way to the end yeah things that
I enjoy the most about that Journey was
uh not seeing uh due dates I don't have
to pay on the fifth
oh I don't have to play on the 17 again
thank God you know so it gives you it
gives you peace yeah the whole thing
changes the the only thing was that as
as we paid the smaller one
um then we have more money for the next
one you know and it got to a point that
we were paying six to seven thousand
dollars a month you know and and like
everything I think we were tried as soon
as we started like we started like in
February of of 2021 and in May my son
got into an accident in my car and
totaled the car totaled the car um
scariest thing that I've ever
experienced in my life
um but thankfully nothing happened to
him but then that set us back uh a month
yeah the money that we needed to use for
the for the debt and we had to we had to
do to get a new car not a new car no I
mean I knew two Oscar right now the
thing is is you have a lot of people
around you telling you no but you're in
a good position to finance a car you
just get a car yeah so many people were
telling us just buy a car just buy a
brand new car put a small down payment
that's okay and we're like no we just
started this journey we cannot fall back
yeah the book will hit you in the face
you gotta be aware of this book you know
so um definitely I mean obviously we
didn't get into that and uh it took us a
couple of weeks and uh we found a
reliable car you know for six actually
six uh 6 500 which is the amount of
money that we normally were paying uh to
the debt
um funny stories that the guy that sold
it to us had just put it online five
minutes before we saw it I mean where
that first one was that saw it next day
we were buying it because we had the
cash so uh you know the the trials or
you know that the tests are going to
come whenever you are focused on
something you know just make sure that
you do not you know yeah exactly from
what you really want to do so how's it
feel to be free it's amazing it's a
brand yeah was it worth it oh man oh 100
you sleep better you dance better
[Laughter]
you talk better you walk better
everything is a lot a lot better yes so
for the people out there who are normal
who are you know spending on credit who
or where you guys were before how do
they go from that to where you are now
because you guys are obviously on fire
like you Dove all in what would you tell
that person yeah it's just discipline
you got to have the discipline to not
buy those cute pair of shoes and you can
save that outfit for another time you
know for me especially I love shoes and
clothes so yeah that was for me it was a
discipline just trying not to focus on
those things that will get me in trouble
she didn't buy anything for a long time
for like a whole year anyway anything I
was so proud of her yeah for me I think
the most important thing is that the
mindset change you know the the behavior
like you said right 80 behavior is 20
math and it really is stuff that you
don't understand until you go through it
um and that's that's that's one of the
main things one thing I want to say
though also is I think for you to be
successful in anything having the the
right support system or having the right
people uh next to you helps a lot I'll
give you a quick example of what what I
mean by that I have my my friends and
family they're friends that became
family you know Johnny Carla David and
and Nino David right I'm a big fan of
yours oh yeah yeah he was talking to us
about Ramsay for about four years and I
didn't even remember the name
we were not ready to receive what he had
to give you know and once he knew that
we were trying to buy a house and all of
this stuff but he knew where we were
because we're friends
um then one day he knocked on my door at
my house and he hit you with a boss
the book is violent he knocked on the
door all he did he didn't even say hi or
anything he walked in put that book on
the table popped me in the back and
walked out
and I'm like what's going on and and
that's and that's actually how I started
so we are super super grateful for you
guys uh because without friends like
that you know cheering us on and and
giving us accountable yes uh it's really
really hard to do you know not only then
our family too they're super happy
because they've seen where we were you
know and now they see where we are yeah
so guys we've got the live and give
bundle for you yes The Total Money
Makeover book The Baby Steps millionaire
book and a membership to Financial Peace
University you ready to do a debt free
scream let's do it love it all right
Amar and Jennifer from Orlando 103
000 paid off in 18 months making 77 to
125. count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're dead
free
hahaha
nice dance move for those of you looking
deeply into your radio you missed that
but go back and watch it on YouTube it's
worth the trouble well done you guys
that's a home run this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Allen's number one
best-selling author Ramsey personality
is my co-host today open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Lara is with us in Austin Texas hi
Laura how are you I'm fine thank you for
taking my call today sure how can we
help
well I have two adult daughters
um one my husband and I do 34 and 35 and
the 35 year old
is married and lives in Colorado
and a year ago uh October we were going
to go take a trip up to see her but due
to the pandemic and our very different
views on masking and social distancing
and all of that
it ended up we had a heated conversation
and she has
cut us out of her life completely
so we got a letter from her the
following day an email saying we're all
done we wouldn't have anything to do
with us we changed her number things for
email
and all cards and correspondence have
been returned unopened so I waited a
whole year
and
you know I have a will we have a will we
both have Wills
um basically it's a 50 50 for our girls
um but
given where we're at now I'm like I
don't feel comfortable if I were to die
tomorrow to leave that daughter money if
she won't even contact me or take my
calls
and I don't know how to handle that
whether I should is it appropriate for
me to change my will or should I look at
it like I'm well I'm not going to be
here I won't know anything about that
just leave it and move on
I'm so sorry
uh it well I waited a year because it's
like a death no it's it's
worse than a death
because they're still there
yes
she you know struggled because the the
her sister had cut her out as well a few
months before us so Simon your other
daughter just got married and her sister
didn't come to the wedding
no I'm so sorry no and she wasn't she
didn't invite her because
um oh he knew that the invitation would
have come back I see unopened so nothing
we have not been able unless we drove a
thousand miles to Colorado from Texas we
would never she just returns everything
says refused Return to Sender
so all over all over a mask in Social
distancing
both of which both of which have turned
out to not be true after the smoke
cleared this is so sad
it is and you know we couldn't hug her
and I that was our thing we said well if
we can't hug our daughter when we come
there we don't see the value in US
coming we want to we want to see you and
hug you and you know it's been two years
let's let's get together and it just
wasn't going to be yeah fear is fear is
a sad sad thing
the terror that took over people's
mental uh ability to do uh
the number of these stories out there is
just staggering it's it's the um it's
one of the huge costs of um
the mythology that was out there in the
name of science
um and the cost of uh people believing
one thing and not believing another it's
just so sad it's just so sad it is it is
your heart I mean as a mom as a mom your
heart must be just completely broken so
it is uh what I what you have to do
for you
not because it's an ethical thing or a
moral thing it's a part of your grieving
process is you have to change your will
okay I'm comfortable with no no it's not
it's not it's not it's not about me it's
that's you admitting
what has happened
right in the in the Jewish culture
you'll hear them say you are dead to me
you are dead to me
yes and it goes back to the story
um that was that happened in Jewish
culture that Christians call the story
of The Prodigal Son and you are dead to
me and so dead means that the person is
still alive but there's no longer any
Financial or relational interaction
anymore and in the Jewish culture if you
don't have a financial interaction and
you don't have a relational interaction
it is worse than a death and so that's
it comes from the you know the the
mindset of the prodigal son and that's
what the prodigal son did he came in and
took the inheritance before his father
died and went and squandered it right
you know the story I do and so but that
that there's a reason for all of that in
that culture and
um that is it's a mental health reason
and it's it's for you to process the
loss of your daughter
yes I'm so sorry
yeah though just the changing of the
changing of the will is just a part of
you grieving and recovering from this if
it changes you can always come back if
the situation changes you can always
come back and change it later and you're
not doing this to punish her
because she's not even going to know it
you know and uh I think that that that's
the thing you think about is well when
I'm gone and she would find out that
that's the cost of doing business the
way she's done business
okay and it's uh but that's not that's
not relevant that this is not about
punishment and it's not about revenge
and it's not about vengeance it's not
about hitting back for the hurt this is
about closing the loop closing the
closing the storyline line and uh if we
can open the storyline later
that is fine
um but but it would not be it's not good
mental health for you to leave the will
dangling as a false hope in your mind
and that's what's that's what it's doing
I just I I to throw this in there I
would just offer a bit of a challenge
even if the will is changed
um I think it'd be easy at that point to
just go this story is done and she's cut
out of my life and I want nothing to do
with her and then sit with anger and
unforgiveness I think that especially if
the will is changed in order to get to
the story of The Prodigal Son and be
like that father you have to have a
heart of forgiveness so that if the
daughter ever comes back you receive her
with open arms so I would just encourage
you to also still work through those
emotions and the hurt and the anger that
comes from whatever argument there was
and work on forgiving that daughter so
that if the story continues at some
point you're ready for it and and you
can have a relationship again
yeah and again that's what I'm saying
your motivation is not about hitting
back your motivation is not anger based
it's just sadness it's going this is the
recognition that she's not in our life
and so it is it's illogical and it's bad
psychology and bad spiritual to leave
her in there at this point
um but it's not really anything to do
with her it's got to do with you
and that's kind of what forgive that's
what forgiveness is as well what
Christine's talking about I mean that's
got to do with you not her because she's
not receiving anything
you know because you're not talking to
her there's no way to get to her and you
can't and no I'm not going to show up on
her front porch and confront her
cutting I mean she made this decision
she's a grown-up you cannot control
other people's decisions and you didn't
cause it
um you just disagreed I mean people
disagree about politics and don't speak
for the rest of their lives they
disagree about a piece of furniture and
don't speak for the rest of their lives
and this is
um it's just so low shelf it's so it's
it's not a very high shelf way of living
but it would be sad for the relationship
to end permanently over covid and mass
restriction but this is not up to her
right except her daughter right she
didn't end it her daughter did that's
true but just having the heart of
forgiveness I'm just sitting there open
that's fine if it comes back open be
open-handed yeah if they come back but
you know you cannot make people like you
you cannot make people behave you cannot
make people be nice
um you can't make people grow a brain
that don't have one
um you can't you just can't you just
have to accept them where they are and
just go that's forgiveness I'm just
going to let you be what you is and then
if you ever want to be something
different we'll talk about that too
that's okay but yeah this is the the
this is a dangling thing in your
psychology it's hanging back there you
think about it when you wake up in the
morning and changing the will puts more
closure on this and allows you to move
on past this this loss that's very real
and uh Hang on we're gonna send you a
copy of Dr delony's book on your past
change your future
um I cannot think of a
hardly anything that will be more
hurtful and harmful to have to go
through than that and it is
in many ways worse than a death
sorry I'm so sorry you're facing this
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramsesolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
ERS of Ramsey Solutions broadcasting
from the PODS of moving and storage
Studios it's the Ramsay show we're dead
as dumb cash is king and the paid off
Home Mortgage has taken the place of the
BMW as the status symbol of choice we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships thank you for joining us
America Christina Ellis number one
best-selling author Ramsay personality
is my co-host today we'll take your
calls at triple eight eight two five
five two two five Barbara's in Phoenix
to start this hour off hey Barbara how
are you
I'm well thank you for asking how are
you better than we deserve what's up
well I have uh some rental property and
some cash
and I'm
I'm and I want to leave all of this
money to my children and I want to get
rid of these four last rentals but I
have parents that's been in there for a
long time and I don't know should I lose
money by letting them stay in there
because they're comfortable or should I
sell them and put the money aside how
are you losing money
I said I'm not lose well I'll because of
the the market is going down
and I feel like if I wait another year
I'm going to get a year left
and income I mean not an income but uh
for the sale yeah
okay are you ill
am I ill are you sure no no I'm not a
kid okay all right just asking so um
well Phoenix has had some price
adjustment uh part of the but it's not
had a lot of value adjustment the
difference is that some of the
properties were priced up up up up
because it was such a hot market and now
they're not pricing them quite so crazy
but the values have held overall uh the
houses are bringing less than they were
asking before but they we're not seeing
a huge drop in value in Phoenix and I
don't think that you're going to lose
substantial money in one year
um and and if you may if you make it two
years then you're probably going to make
money by keeping them are they under
rented it sounds like you don't you're
not charging enough rent the way you
describe it I'm not charging enough
right but we're comfortable I I don't
need any money
I know so uh I would rather help those
people that's struggling than men make
any extra money and pay it out to the
government because I do pay
uh taxes on it sure sure okay
um
so you have tenants that are charity
cases
yes for the most part they don't fix
income yet okay
um well here's the deal all right if um
do your kids yeah your kids probably
don't want the real estate right they
probably just rather they don't they
don't want it okay what did you pay for
these rentals and have you been
appreciating them for many many years
you know what I I bought them in the 70s
and I paid uh nothing for five houses
less than a hundred thousand dollars and
the group is worth what now
right now uh
uh I would say three quarters of a
million yeah okay
so here's the thing if you sell that
area yeah if you sell them now
you're gonna pay capital gains
on the difference in what you sell them
for and your basis your adjusted basis
which your basis is what you paid for
them minus the depreciation that you
have taken and you probably depreciated
them all the way out you're probably
going to pay taxes on every dollar that
you sell them for
if you sell them out okay right if
instead you do a will do you have a will
yes I have a will and live until I see
it okay then in the will leave detailed
instructions to the executor of the
estate who's the executor one of your
kids yes that they are to sell the
properties upon your death and
distribute the proceeds
okay here's why
when they inherit 750 000 worth of
market value property if they sell it
for 750 000 there's zero tax
if you sell it you're going to pay tax
on all of it okay okay that's what I
needed to know there's a stepped up
basis your zero basis becomes more their
basis is market value at death
your basis is what you paid for it minus
the depreciation you've taken which has
probably got these houses at zero basis
or close
yes okay and so you're going to pay
taxes on almost the whole thing they're
going to pay taxes on nothing but and
they can sell it and turn it into money
you know three weeks after you're gone
or whatever the proper proper procedure
is in Arizona but I needed to hear yeah
but leave instructions that way your
your heirs don't think well Mama wanted
us to keep these properties and take
care of these people on fixed income
because that's not what mama wants mama
wants these things sold
yes so be sure you write that down and
say it out loud for everybody to read
matter of fact make it an instruction in
the will the properties are to be
liquidated upon my death and the
proceeds dispersed
equally or whatever you want it to be
okay
that's the right answer you can check
with your estate planning attorney and
with your tax person and they will both
confirm that this is actually one piece
of tax law that I do know most of it I
don't but that one I do know inside and
out that's so good I feel like I'm
learning something and I think that's
just such a gift to give such clear
instructions upon death and the will oh
it's so helpful because otherwise it's
always who shot John right so mama said
last time I was with mama she said and
that's the way you know these arguments
go on for
ever and it's like you and you end up
keeping some stupid piece of real estate
because of some rumor of what mama said
you know and so no you got to make it
very clear and in this case we're
talking about
probably uh 150 200 000 worth of
difference in tax
that one phone call wow yeah
and that's just such a highlight of you
know
you know dumb to ask you I mean maybe
there are some dumb questions but
especially in the world of taxes and
wills and leaving things to your heirs
these are important questions to ask
that literally could have just saved her
so much money yeah and the beauty of it
is I mean obviously she's sharp as
attack I mean no question about that
lady she on game on right there but
she's got a will she's built a million
dollar estate you know she's a
millionaire sitting there in Phoenix
she's watching the Phoenix market like a
hawk I mean This Woman's not sitting
back drinking Ovaltine I'm just saying
she's she's getting her done man I love
it so uh she's cool and uh that's who
that's who we want to be when we grow up
when we're 80. I know I'm Gonna Be A
Millionaire managing the estate for tax
efficiency wow
very sophisticated there very well done
Barbara very well done and uh that
that's the things everyone you guys need
a will if you're over 18 years old you
need a will if you hate the people that
you're in your family
leave unclear instructions and no will
because they will all fight the rest of
your the rest of their lives over your
crap
and it'll cost them like an extra
bazillion dollars in attorney's fees and
court costs
it'll all get tied up in court and
delayed oh yeah you can completely screw
up people's lives leaving them your
stuff poorly and if you love them do the
opposite
Crystal Clear detailed game plan
signed notarized and witnessed Wills go
to mamabearlegalforms.com get your
stinking will in place this is the
Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality is my
co-host today for 30 years we've taught
people how to live like no one else so
that one day they can give like no one
else and live like no one else and as it
turns out the world is full of generous
people there's even a special day to
recognize it it's giving Tuesday to
celebrate we want to share one way you
can show radical generosity and have a
huge impact on kids across the country
think back to when you first learned the
baby steps and how to handle your money
the right way you probably thought I
wish I'd learned this when I was in high
school our foundations and personal
finance curriculum is the money course
you wish you'd had then and it's been in
48 percent of America's high schools but
thousands of schools every year can't
teach it because they don't have the
funds through our curriculum sponsorship
program businesses and individuals team
up with us to sponsor the curriculum
into a high school they choose you might
send it like your old high school or
something or your old high school and uh
your uh rival old high school or
whatever that kind of stuff right you
can sponsor curriculum for one or two
students or whole school or whole or
whole city we've had businesses take on
the whole city lots of times if you're
willing to live and give like no one
else so you can sponsor for an entire
school give today go to
ramseysolutions.com
sponsor our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out whyblinds.com
is the number one online retailer of
custom window coverings free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
always use the promo code Ramsey to get
the best best possible deal today's
question comes from Peter in Alabama my
wife got accepted into the nurse
practitioner program at the University
of Alabama and will start in January
this program is highly competitive and
will more than double her pay when she
graduates we started the baby steps
about a month ago and are on baby step
two we have decided that student loans
are not an option for us and we're going
to cash flow her school we have
researched scholarships grants employer
paid programs and looked at your
resources but have not had much luck
with finding help for students in a
graduate school program hoping you can
point us in the right direction because
any little bit will help
it's very interesting I would definitely
have more questions about where they are
in baby step two and kind of what the
reality is but I would also have a
challenge to say you know how much have
you searched first of all finding money
for graduate school is more difficult
than undergrad there's not as much
funding available so it does take some
digging
um a lot of people do end up having to
cash flow it through their job but I
would also encourage you to look
especially with nursing at different
employers that are offering tuition
assistance you said you've already
looked at that but I happen to know that
UAB medicine University of Alabama
medicine has an awesome tuition
assistance program so if you haven't
looked into that I would definitely
encourage you to go ahead and see if
that's an option the reality is I think
a lot of people give up too easy when it
comes to looking for money to pay for
college they look for scholarships for
an hour or two or they quickly do a
Google Search and they don't see
something immediately and they go well
there's nothing out there and they get
frustrated but the the truth is is it
takes time you have to be willing to dig
and dig and dig until you find a
solution that works for you I love that
you've taken student loans off the table
because that's step one you know if you
don't have that as an option you either
won are going to have to really dig and
figure out what it's going to take
whether that's working your tail off to
be able to cash flow it digging for
scholarships looking for employer
tuition programs or perhaps you may need
to look at a different program or put
pause for a little bit hit pause until
you can afford to pay for it with cash I
just think being willing to take that
extra step to continue strategizing is
so key yeah but I I think you say um
until I have invested
40 hours
and you log the hours
searching scratching emailing texting
going through computers talking to
people until you've spent 40 solid hours
working on scholarships you haven't
really looked yet
four minutes with a Google search does
not count that does not count there's
not a magic button if that if that were
the case everyone would go get a
scholarship exactly and there's not
enough scholarship money out there for
everyone to get a full ride especially
for grad school it's it's a limited
resource so if you want to be the person
to get it you got to be willing to put
in the time and effort it's a hard
reality because I wish there was enough
money for everyone to go debt free with
scholarships but scholarships
specifically there's a limited pool now
there is I believe anybody can get a
debt-free education if they're willing
to hustle and grind and look for
employer tuition assistance so if her
pay is more than double when she
graduates she's probably already a nurse
right is that what we're saying that's
what I'm going to show you I think you
may I would change jobs
and go to work for somebody pays for it
UAB is a great option it's called a huge
raise
when they start paying for your nurse
practitioner school and the other place
doesn't even if you took a pay cut
but you got all your tuition free ding
ding well and even same thing with
scholarships how you're like you know
until you've spent 40 hours until you've
called every single Hospital in town
until you've called every every doctor's
office anyone who could possibly need a
nurse like you haven't put in the work
that will you know if you're currently a
nurse and they don't have tuition
payment our tuition assistance is
substantial then then shop your job 100
and I would change jobs because you're
going to change jobs anyway when you
finish the nurse practitioner thing and
you know and so you know go do that and
uh you know it's the guy who takes a job
as a um groundskeeper at the University
but the university gives all employees
free tuition to their children you know
yeah I'm gonna go cut grass buddy heck
yeah you know and for a period of time
here because that's that's that's the
best paid Lawn Care guy on the planet
right now if you put three kids through
there right I mean you know what I'm
saying that kind of stuff so you just
think about it differently for a short
period of time and you plug yourself
into that this is not a way of life for
a decade this is a thing to do to get
there absolutely yeah it's a temporary
change you know for long-term benefits
Daniel is in Chicago hi Daniel welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey Dave hey what's up
hey uh so
um I recently got married I've been with
uh my now wife for about 10 years um
she's gonna graduate dental school in uh
in May
um she's so she's bringing in about 750
000 in student loans
um and uh other than that she's got a
yeah I'm sorry what is her degree what
is she doing 750 000 in debt for
uh dentist oh Jesus Murphy
Murphy yeah it's a good school but it's
expensive
um you have no idea what you just said
yeah
um but uh yeah it's I've got about 40
000 in debt from what seems like you
guys call normal debt credit cards car
stuff like that
um and uh
I mean she's gonna make good money you
know but it's just I can't see the light
at the end of the tunnel you know it's
it's how do we dig ourselves out of that
hole
and he said she's graduated or she's
still no she she will graduate in May
does she have a job lined up or what's
your plan for after graduation
um so I'm not too Savvy on all that
she's waiting for some sort of
she's waiting for some sort of thing
that she need before she can start
applying
um it's pretty much is like her
credentials
um to show off to Future employers so
she's waiting for that before she starts
applying
um but in the market she's been looking
already it seems like she's going to
start off somewhere between 175 to 225 a
year
okay well here's the thing
um
I can tell by the
language you're using in your sentence
structure
um that it is you guys have not grasped
how devastating a situation you're in
and with that
um
what a huge mistake this was
and part of solving this is going to be
that you say out loud and she says out
loud this what what has happened here
it's in the rearview mirror and I'm not
trying to shame her but you have in
order to run away from a problem you
first have to realize that it's a
problem
and um the language you're using is
minimizing this like you owe thirty
dollars to somebody or something and
it's no big deal but it was a good
school it's not a good school
she paid double what she should have
paid
for her Dentistry degree double she got
screwed yep she got screwed
and you guys are up a creek you're in a
real mess so if you will live like your
absolute poor people
and go make 300 or 400 000 between the
two of you you can pay this off in maybe
three years and get your life back or
you can be a normal dentist and keep
this around for the next two decades
and that's what most dentists do
the dental degrees are the most
overcharged overpriced degree of every
degree out there right now and this one
is double the normal one
wow this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
Christina Ellis Ramsey personality
number one best-selling author is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Sierra is with us Sierra is in Kansas
City hi Sierra how are you
hey doing great just want to give a
quick shout out to Austin in the booth
he is awesome oh he's amazed he's
absolutely amazing he actually he
actually runs the company but we don't
tell anybody
I would believe it how can we help
um so my husband and I we went through
financial peace in the end of September
um all my lessons in like nine days
perfect and we have been chuggling for
two months now we're in baby step two
and we've paid off 18 of our total debt
so we are fired up boom boom yes
um but looking ahead
um our lease is up in April and we're
not going to be able to stay here it's
just not going to meet our needs and
just like you told us in Financial Peace
we're seeing our credit score dropping
which we expected
um but in order to rent in our area we
got to maintain at least some credit
which I hate I'm ready that's not true
okay completely not true listen we had
one of our personalities call uh 10 or
15 of the apartment complexes in our
area and our area is very similar to
yours and ask them how if they required
a credit score in order to move in and
only one out of ten should they did
requiring a credit score but what about
if our credit score hasn't disappeared
yet I think you just sit down with a
manager and you say I've got a low
credit score because I'm paying off all
my debts and I'm working the Dave Ramsey
plan and they will gladly lease to you
with a deposit okay and you know and
especially if you're working with an
individual landlord that has an
individual house
that's not a corporation right right
yeah if you can't I mean like I've got a
bunch of houses if you came to a guy
like me and said listen uh yeah you're
going to find my credit score 645 but
it's not because I have bad credit it's
because I'm paying off everything and my
credit score is dying I'm trying to kill
it we would be going right yes what's
the best tenant one that doesn't have
any other debt they can pay the rent
very very true
um so
I guess that is definitely probably the
best option we had two
things that we came up with I wanted to
kind of run by you to see what you think
okay
um so knowing that we're going to be
moving in April we were thinking either
one go into storm mode
pile up all the money until we have
moved and then just press play and throw
that all in the dead again
or why do you need a pile of money to
rent
we have to get a deposit we have to get
all of that kind of stuff together
well you gotta you have to plan to be
able to do that but I don't know that
you need to have like I mean fifteen
thousand dollars or something
right I guess I'm still thinking of it
like my credit score issue
so you're right so if I'm not worried
about the credit then it doesn't matter
do you think Dave it would be a good
exercise for her to go ahead and start
calling apartment complexes today so she
can one
work through the credit score fears and
then two figure out exactly what her
deposit is going to need to be yeah
that's good planning and if you know if
you've got to stop or slow down your
debt snowball in order to have the money
to make the move that's fine
but now listen what's your current rent
uh currently we're renting at 1200 a
month okay and so if you go up in rent
you're going to slow down your whole
life
right we're not looking to really go
much
we're looking to stick around this okay
good the thing is where we're at in the
market what we're paying for is an
equivalent to things around us for the
same price and we're looking to start a
family so we need something better okay
that's fine there's no problem with that
at all
um
as long as you're staying in that same
uh price range and yeah but yeah go
ahead and start calling some places and
look at some of the newspapers 1500 or
you know 1300 bucks or whatever like
that and you go okay here's the move I'm
gonna make and just call them and Shop
it like Christina said and that helps
you put your budget together well they
may say you know you need two months as
a deposit and then you have that Clarity
you set aside 24 2500 and then you
continue with the debt snowball because
I love how aggressive you've been the
fact that you've already tore through 18
is amazing and I don't want you to lose
that momentum just holding on to the
money kind of getting complacent and
waiting all the way till April I think
you guys can you know set aside the
deposit and then continue with you know
so much fire in your belly that you
don't slow that down okay so we have a
reality the reality is the move and
let's let facts be our friends not
Theory and Hyperbole and drama
yes that makes sense and that's kind of
my biggest fear is I don't want to lose
the momentum that we're not going
because we are on fire yeah don't don't
over steer don't over correct to make
the move in other words and and so we're
going to shut down and then we have
17 000 and we needed four thousand to
make the move no that would be silly
that's over steering right uh but if you
need if you do a little bit of research
you figure we need three thousand we
need 3 800 bucks to make this move and
then we're going to get our deposit back
when we move and we get that deposit
back we'll throw it at the debt
um you know we just play a little cash
game here with hide the P under the
shell and uh you know then that that's
just good planning but the unknown
sometimes makes us over steer and go
into drama mode right and drama mode can
stop that momentum I love that you
called because you can hear it in your
voice you are on fire it gets me fired
up just hearing you talk so get it get
it yeah get it Well Done Amy's in
Sacramento hi Amy how are you
that's okay how are you
thank you so much for taking my call I
really appreciate it I'm new to the Baby
Rosie steps and I wish I knew about this
a month before I bought my house um so
my question is did I buy my house on a
uh emotional level and should I have
stepped back so my question now is do I
gracefully determine how to get out of
this house or do I make peace with
myself and plan to uh save so that I
eventually can stay here for quite a
while
so what what emotions were you feeling
when you bought the house
so about seven months ago my husband
died and I have three children
um one is 20 the other's uh 8 17 and one
is 11. and so
um I I was you know feeling welcome to
feelings and um it's been a little bit
hard sure
um dealing with everything going on the
other rationale is we are also separated
for about three years
um and it was not an amicable even my
divorce was never finalized but
um I felt like you know I I definitely
need to find stability for my three
children I want to make sure that all
the changes that that's going on since
the divorce and then especially now that
they're attending the same school the
same district you know all and just have
a stable home because I was renting
after I separated yeah Amy so I'm sorry
what you've been through I'm so sorry
thank you what what did you pay for the
house
I did pay for the house I said what did
you what did you pay for it
um how much I was like
765
000. okay and what did you did you get a
mortgage or used life insurance or how
did you pay for it
he had no life insurance
my entire life
um and when we separated I I paid
aluminum and child support as well
um so that's the other rationale for why
I felt like I'm not questioning right
I'm just trying to figure out the math
okay sure there's a lot of reasons that
are valid for you to have emotion around
this so um what is your payment on your
house
I know I'm saying well well number one
will be my very first payment
paying right about 5k
5K a month five thousand dollars a month
okay and what is your income
clearly I think about 120k
you have other income coming in
yes I was just about to mention I have
social security and a small pension from
him
how much
for about 4 500 a month
okay so your take-home pay is about 12
000 bucks right
with all this yes
okay your your house payment is very
high
yes it's very high
um I'm so sorry you're in this situation
I'm so sorry how you got here
but I regardless of how you got there or
what your motives were or your reasons
for getting there your house payment is
very high
and you know that and that's why you
call me
so I don't want to add pain to a life
that's full of pain already but I want
you to really look at that and begin
thinking about it
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host today open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five
okay uh Financial counseling life hack
moment I just created a new segment for
the show
um
from having done this financial coaching
for 30 plus years and having done it
one-on-one knee Captain he kept kneecap
many times
um started years ago doing it as a
Ministry in our church just to help
people and they would come in and sit
down help them do their budget and help
them do this stuff and and it evolved
into this whole thing that we all call
Ramsey now
um
one of the things that I've seen over
and over and over again and it's so much
so that it's almost a stereotype uh it's
not always true and generalizations are
always dangerous but I'll give you a
generalization I'll tell you what
happens a lot
and this is a life hack for those of you
out there and you're facing and it comes
from our last caller okay
a couple with um two little kids in
elementary school go through a divorce
now right wrong or indifferent here's
the math
most of the time the husband makes more
money than the wife
not saying that's right I'm just saying
it's factual okay typically I sit down
with a couple
two jobs sometimes it's the way around
but it's it oftentimes the husband makes
more money in the wife or she's a
stay-at-home mom which of course he
makes more money than she makes at that
point
the going through a divorce with little
kids in the home going through a divorce
period is an absolute
um
it's walking through hell
barefooted I mean it's awful it's a
horrible thing it's hard on Mom it's
hard on Dad it's hard on family it's her
own friends it's hard on your church
Community it's hard on your kids it's
hard on everybody everybody in the mix
is hurting
no one's thinking clearly
and everyone's trying to take their
little corner of the world and Keep It
Sane in the middle of massive insanity
and here's what normally happens
Mom and Dad split up we now don't have a
two income family or now we have
um uh a lady and Mom the lady in the
divorce with less income
certainly than she had before but less
income than he makes normally
wants to keep the house
that they bought based on his income
being in the picture
in order that the children can stay in
the school
because their lives are already
upheavaled their lives are already
upside down and to make them move and
have to change schools in the middle of
all that makes it almost unbearable for
mother bear
and mother bear just wants to protect
and in the name of that in the divorce
settlement she gets the house with
payments that she can't afford
and so she has traded one kind of stress
unbeknownst and with good no Bill Noble
intent she traded the stress of the
children having to move and being
uprooted out of a school to the children
living in a household that is absolutely
starving to death and broke due to a
house payment they can't afford
and so it became
something that almost every single week
I had the
uh horrible job of sitting and looking
at Mama Bear and explaining to her the
best thing you can do for your children
is to uproot them and live in a house
you can afford
after this is clear because you cannot
afford this house you are living a
you're trying to hold on to a picture as
Dr John Loney says of what was and make
it what is and it is not there anymore
and you cannot support this house
payment
on half of the income or less than half
of the income or way less than half of
the income uh in most cases it ends up
being in an effort to keep the kids
stabilized in a highly volatile
situation in their schools you end up
destabilizing them for the next decade
because they're living with a single mom
now who's working three jobs trying to
keep a house that she can't afford so
that they cannot have to trade schools
you traded one kind of destabilization
one kind of stress in the house for the
kids for another kind and
unintentionally with Noble intent you're
trying to protect your children but
you're making a bad decision sell the
house and the divorce
almost always sell the house on the
divorce now our last caller was
different they were separated he passed
away and in the middle of all that she
bought a house she couldn't afford
that's a little different but it still
had the same net result we've still got
an 11 year old and a older teenager who
was 16 or 17 living in a house full of
stress
and you could hear it in her voice I'm
sad it was very sad and you could hear
the remorse too yeah I made a mistake
you could feel it yeah because she did
make a mistake and it was it's not to
shame her or to beat her up because I've
done Dumber things believe me but but
you know what you have to be careful of
is that in the middle of all of that
crisis Dr John talks about this all the
time that our our critical thinking
skills break down we we just grab at
anything that feels stable trying to
keep some
version of our past life that we liked
still intact going forward and in in a
lot of cases that takes the form of
keeping the house after the divorce and
the house is a house we can't afford and
it's like trying to swim with an anchor
tied around your ankle and keep your
head above water for the next decade and
uh that's why I run into a lot of
divorcey ladies with little kids at home
they're getting child support maybe
they're getting alimony and but they're
working three jobs
to try to support a house payment
to create this false
sense of stability
while being unstable right you know with
the kids and it's just so sad because
the intent is so sweet it's such a mama
bear wonderful thing to think about to
protect the kids and the noble to take
this but you're really not accomplishing
your goal right because what the kids
need more than anything is you they need
your presence they need your peace and
if you're stressed about money if you
can't afford your house payment you're
not going to be who you want to be I
would rather you be at home after work
instead of going to your second and
third job
then go to that school 100 Kids train
schools all the time ask people in the
military ask people in Corporate America
that move every two years kids change
schools all the time and they survive
and some of them even thrive in that
situation and so you know it's a
falsehood to say Well they're going to
lose all their friends they're going to
they're 11.
they're going to be okay
but you're you're you're bringing
another kind of damage another kind of
stress into their lives in an effort to
protect the other one that's an
unintended consequence it's there was no
one doing this it was not selfish greed
it was not some uh you know a selfish uh
princess that bought something that she
couldn't afford this is a mama trying to
take care of her kids so it's the
highest of all motives the most noble of
all motives but it's still ending in
uh an unintended consequence that is
actually worse than what they were
trying to protect from right
and I think it's just it highlights just
that need to slow down when you're in
those situations when your critical
thinking has gone down you're in crisis
mode to slow down because it is so easy
to grasp at straws to grasp at things
that you think will help but just taking
that time to breathe and to you know
just let let what logic can come back
come back you know it's almost like the
it's really scary to rescue someone
that's drowning because they can drown
you
you know because they're they're just
flailing around out there and there's a
little bit of that going on you know and
so uh this is just a life hack it's
again it's a generalization it's not
always true I have talked to people that
you know they divorce a guy who's got 20
million dollars and he leaves them 18
million dollars and they go pay cash for
a house well shut up that's not who I'm
talking about okay it's not that's not
the thing or or you know in the divorce
I get uh he makes a million dollars a
year and I get alimony of you know
enough to pay the payments and still
have plenty of margin that's not what
I'm talking about but I'm talking about
a a typical template is not any of those
things a typical template is still in
America right or wrong I'm not I'm not
it's not right ladies ought to make as
much for the same job as a man makes you
know I'm not I'm not that guy so uh but
uh but in in most households mom does
not out earn dad in America today still
and so when she ends up with a house
with a lesser income
and um
it's she oftentimes can't afford it so
that's a life hack for you as painful as
it feels like in the moment the best
long-term play is sell the house
it's just a house
it's just a school
there's schools and houses everywhere
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS of
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as dumb cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships
Christina Ellis number one best-selling
author Ramsay personality is my co-host
today
our phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five Aurora is
with us in Portland Oregon hi Aurora how
are you
hi I'm good thank you good how can we
help today
um so I the last couple of weeks I've
been kind of um you know been watching
all of your guys's stuff on YouTube I
actually found you guys on Tick Tock and
um yeah and I've just been kind of you
know the last couple of months I've been
really trying to
um get settled and pay off debt and just
seems like any way that I try I I can't
and I always refer back to living
paycheck to paycheck and I just I'm kind
of over it I I I don't feel like I'm
content where like where I am in life
and so I feel like part of that is just
having so much debt and you know having
kids to take care of and wanting to plan
for them and I don't I don't know like
where to start I don't know what to do
anymore boy I like you you're in a
really really good place thank you for
calling and I like you just because you
mentioned to Dave that you found us
through tick tock
Dave loves Tick Tock I'm not sure if
that speaks poorly of you or of me but
one of the two okay
I love it
yeah my birthday today so I'm like you
know what happy birthday glad you got
through it thank you like if it's not
today then I don't know what day is yeah
it's a great day to call so walk us
through the debt how much debt do you
have
well um I've paid up I paid off quite a
bit now but um I have about 21 000 I
would say between my partner and I
um that we still need to pay off and
most of it is credit card debt so so you
said you paid it off uh tell us about
the debt you paid off
um so that you know while when they were
giving the uh unemployment during covet
it took months for me to get my like
checks um because everything was so
behind and when I finally got like my
claim it wasn't that much um I paid off
my car I was like this is one thing that
I need to you know get rid of because
God forbid I you know can't work anymore
I can't find another job but I need that
you know I need that to get around yeah
I just want to stop and applaud you for
that because the fact that you're
already you know Wheels in Motion you
paid off your car that's that's great
yeah so what's your income yeah
um between my partner and I unique about
5500. okay let me stop a second are you
married
no we're not we live together okay all
right so legally you are too you have a
roommate
and for the handling from the handling
of your money that's the way the law is
going to look at it
right yeah so um you pay off your
partner's debt you get zero credit for
that with the law
okay so you're combining your money with
your roommate is a bad idea
yeah because of where you stand legally
so how much the 21 000 is that all in
your name
no okay what is in your name
ten thousand okay what is that on
uh that is credit card debt okay and um
good and you paid off your car way to go
and what do you make
uh I make two uh a month it's about
twenty two hundred okay all right good
for you and how old are you
I'm 28. and what do you do for a living
I am an elementary school secretary
oh well thank you for your service
thanks for what you do for the kiddos
okay so if you've been watching the
videos are you familiar with the term
gazelle intense
uh no I don't know not yet
Dave can you do your Dave exclamation
mark
the best oh okay so here's the thing
what we have figured out is is that
personal finance is 80 Behavior it's 20
head knowledge and so for for your
partner
with their money we'll tell them to do
exactly the same thing you're doing but
not combined but not combined okay so
we'll have the same result that you're
looking for but when you combine them
you leave yourself open to other
problems that we don't want to get into
okay like who who bought the mustard or
whatever all that garbage right so
um now uh so the what we if personal
finance is 80 behavior that means when I
get control of me
I have the best possible control and of
My outcome with my money the more
intense I get
the deeper I sacrifice and the deeper I
sacrifice the more money goes towards
cleaning up the mess and the quicker I
get stabilized
and moving towards wealth
so in other words if you goof around
with this stuff and sort of kinda do it
and you still go out to eat and you
still go on vacation and you still buy a
bunch of crap that hasn't got anything
to do with the goal of getting rid of
these credit cards it's going to take
twice as long and you're going to be
half as likely to ever even do it
right and if you get so intense that
it's like yeah if you get so intense
that it's like you're gonna die if you
don't get rid of this credit card debt
in five months then you're gonna work
six jobs and you're gonna eat ramen
noodles and you're not gonna do nothing
but work and get out of debt because
that's intense and sacrifice and that's
what we mean by Consultants like the
gazelle running from the cheetah doesn't
want to be eaten and doesn't want to be
killed they're they're running for their
freaking lives this is not an
intellectual discussion this is very
visceral it's bone marrow you are going
for it right
and that's that's there's something that
happens in 30 years of me doing this
when people get that level of pissed off
that they're willing to cut everything
that their friends think they've lost
their minds they think you've joined a
cult then you're on track so you need to
get out the credit cards when you get
off the phone and chop them all up into
little bitty pieces every one of them
and you need to get on a written budget
and you need to get another job or six
and you're not going out to eat you're
not going to see the inside of a
restaurant unless you're working there
and you're not going on vacation all
you're doing is getting out of debt
because how's it going to feel when you
don't have any debt it's going to feel
really good how's it going to feel when
you don't have any debt have ten
thousand dollars in the bank it's gonna
feel really good we call that Financial
Peace
yes but you're gonna pay a price to get
there you're going to live like no one
else
so later you can live and give like no
one else okay that's what Christine is
talking about
yeah and I'm super encouraged when you
split things out you've got ten thousand
dollars you've got twenty two hundred
dollars a month and you're 28 years old
you can work six jobs you can make the
sacrifices you can do this quickly
you're working in elementary school it's
over 3 30. you've got time to do three
more jobs I mean you really do I mean
you can go make some serious money and
there's people hiring out there like
crazy right now
big time
so and you'll have to do this forever
you just do it for a short period of
time it's a Sprint
you just bust it for a short period of
time
hang on Aurora we like you we're going
to put you through our class called
Financial Peace University we're going
to pay for it watch those classes hold
on I'm going to pay for you to have a
membership you watch every one of them
and do every single thing we said to do
and you'll be wealthy
it's up to you this is the Ramsay show
thank you
[Music]
thank you
hey all you procrastiniters listen up
we've extended our Cyber Monday sale
where you can get our best prices of the
year on your favorite products this week
only best-selling books and tools for as
low as five dollars not exactly jacked
up for inflation but you got to hurry I
think we checked it down maybe it's a
recession these deals end this week you
can shop our quick reads like my latest
the momentum theorem Dr John deloney's
redefining anxiety all under ten dollars
our number one bundle the starter
special is everything you or a loved one
needs to start working the baby steps
and it's only seven and it's 77 percent
off this week and our extended Cyber
Monday sale includes my book baby steps
millionaires number one bestseller for
ten dollars on how to be a millionaire
this is the season to share the hope we
have with others you can get almost any
of these books
Rachel Cruz Ken Coleman Dave Ramsey Dr
John deloney and on and on and on for
ten dollars or less do the hard thing
share your experience give them a
meaningful gift Cyber Monday continues
all week long
ramseysolutions.com or
mcsolutions.com Cara is with us Cara is
in Milwaukee hi Cara how are you
good how are you better than I deserve
how can we help
so I was recently let go for my job
about three weeks ago and I was the
breadwinner for the family my husband
but
yeah I brought in about three thousand
dollars more than he did which is quite
a bit
um and now I'm trying to figure out I do
have another job lined up but it was a
pretty big pay cut from what we're used
to so I'm trying to figure out if I
should borrow money from my 401k to stay
afloat absolutely not because I'll yeah
so and I kind of knew you were going to
say that because I've listened to you
for a long time what does your husband
um so he makes about 45
000 a year and what did you make at the
other job that fired you
86 000. what do you do
uh I was a transportation supervisor for
a chemical company
okay and so you're uh
what you're running distribution or what
I don't understand
um so the company produces things like
um epoxy and bleach stuff like that and
then I organize
um the transportation for all of that
across the country the world stuff like
that okay so you're in a supply chain of
sorts okay yeah all right how long had
you done that
uh I was there for six years okay
and what's the new job what's the new
possibility so the new job is
um kind of the same thing it's a freight
broker but it's for um different
products so not hazardous not chemicals
just like dry goods and arranging the
freight for other companies who could
call yeah what's the pay
uh it's a fifty five thousand dollars
plus commission not good enough
I need to keep looking
yeah yeah you've been out of work you've
been out of work a whole three weeks
yeah here let me tell you okay what
normally happens to normal humans
is that getting fired
is
are getting laid off
whatever term we downsized right size
whatever you want to call it
is
um it's a gut punch
it knocks the breath out of you
it takes some of your confidence and
then you look at your budget and you're
like in your uh lowered confidence state
of mind and your budget is super tight
and super scary we stir those two things
together and we get freak out mode going
yes which causes you to take a job quick
too cheap
you're better than this other job this
new job
aren't you
yes I believe I am yeah yeah and I think
you need to go make something like 86
000 again and in the meantime I want you
to do weird crazy side jobs during
Christmas and your husband too so that
you're not in freak out mode but um I
want you to jump on Ken coleman.com on
his website and study everything on his
uh thing I'm going to send you his two
books proximity principle which is how
you land a lead for the right kind of
job it's probably how you got this lead
because it's in the same industry you
were in or the same type of field and as
somebody you knew you were in proximity
to you didn't get this out of the out of
a an ad on LinkedIn
right
correct yeah you got it because you knew
somebody
um
oh and by the way they might want you
about enough to pay you 80 instead of
55.
yeah when you decide to walk away
instead of taking it say I you know I I
think I'm worth this in the market I
understand that's what you're paying I'm
not trying to be insulting to you but I
think I can get this doing this job I'm
yeah I got eight years of experience of
uh you know organizing Transportation
Nationwide worldwide to cause products
to be delivered on time and and people
that can run schedules like that they
don't grow on trees they're not
everywhere and I'm sitting here with all
this experience and I can make your I
can make your operation hum but I can't
do it for 55 I can do it for 85.
and do you guys have
fun
um so we actually my husband and I did
start going back through the baby step
so I took the course the the Financial
Peace Corps probably like eight years
ago at this point and that's where I
laid out my budget which I still use
today and then I got married we had
another kid so all this stuff and we
kind of got off track yeah so we started
over so we do have a very small savings
and we're going back through our debt
snowball he didn't believe in the debt
snowball so I made him watch these
videos and listen to one of your audio
books and all this stuff and he's like
okay I'm on board for it and then I got
terminated so we were there and we're
trying to stay there but it's hard
wanting to stay there with all of the
deals so I if you go get both of you go
get two good paying
extra jobs for 30 days instead of
tapping your 401k and you go get a job
making the money you're actually worth
Kara you are worth 80 to 90 000 a year
in this job environment where there is a
shortage of Labor where it is hard to
find good people who are willing to work
you are worth that and you can get that
job it's out there
okay and I I don't want you to settle
and I would rather you have him deliver
pizzas and you do Uber each or whatever
it is you guys do for extra money right
really I'd rather you do that for 30
days and get a job making 90 than to get
a job making 55 because you got scared
right after you got gut punched
yep
and go down to a Bare Bones budget I'm
encouraged to hear that you're on a
budget but cut out everything everything
yep you can't afford to eat out you're
broke you're living on 45 000 a year
and you used to have 120
my church was kind enough to give us a
gift card for the grocery store and set
up a meal train so that can amen yeah
that's that's that's the there's no
shame in that at all and you can do that
for someone else if you live and give
like no one else later you can live and
give like no one else you'll be in a
position to return that and pay it
forward so I want you to do all of that
and we're going to help you too I'm
going to send you Ken Coleman's two
books one's paycheck to purpose and the
other one is proximity principle and
there's a bunch of free stuff on how to
put together the proper resume how to
write the proper letter and how to come
in contact with the people they're going
to lead you to the next job because what
you need are more options and the
options are going to come when you get
your Swagger back and you are deserving
of swagger
yes thank you okay uh you are there's a
I'm also going to send you the momentum
theorem which isn't my last little quick
read I'm gonna send you so many books
all you're going to be reading okay but
um give you something to do and
the momentum theorem one of the things
we start out with in that is when things
are going super good you got momentum
you're not as good as you look
things are better than you are when
things are going super bad you're not as
bad as you look
you got you're better than the
circumstances indicate and that's where
you're living right this second
you are better than your circumstances
indicate
and you need to hear someone that's
outside of the forest to say that to you
and I just said that to you and I love
you and I want you to win
so you hold on Austin's gonna pick up
we're going to give you those three
books momentum theorem paycheck to
purpose and proximity principal Ken
coleman.com we'll send you where you
need to go to get all kinds of goodies
to uh resumes ideas everything how to
how to how to a letter to write to get
in the door the email to write to get in
the door all that kind of stuff it's all
right there it's all helpful on Career
stuff this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
's number one best-selling author Ramsay
personality is my co-host in the lobby
of Ramsey Solutions on the debt-free
stage Corey and Kimberly are with us hey
guys how are you great how are you great
welcome to Nashville where do you live
we live in Sandusky Ohio ah fun good to
have you welcome thank you good good
good so how much debt have you paid off
270 000 that was our business loan that
we bought we had like a Pepper charm
franchise that um they're like little
routes that you buy so
um we bought that my my whole family is
actually in the business and um like my
dad owned the territory and then I
bought it from him or part of it anyways
the bakery part of it and then my other
brother runs the Snyders and all that so
so it's all a big family of area we do
that and then we did that in 2019 we
bought that and that was a 162
000 that we buy and then in 2020 March
of 2020 we bought our house oh yeah
literally the week of covid when
everything was falling off every week we
actually bought our house like in the
middle of March yeah there's a week it
went crazy March 20th so yeah when they
said go home you're going to die yeah I
remember that weekend
wait a minute I just bought a house I
love it yeah absolutely yeah so that was
um so is this your house and everything
yes that's everything so I'm looking at
weird people you're 100 Deadpool yeah
I love it just in time yeah I love it so
uh how long did this take
I started in May of 2019 and then we
paid it all off by September 30th of
this year so all of it completely so
what does that end up about 30 months is
that sound about right about two and a
half years something yeah closer to
three something like that okay I'll call
it three okay I can't do it in my head
right now all right so your range of
income during that three years so when
we first bought it the route my whole
route was doing like maybe a hundred
thousand a year and then it was
consistent I guess but then covet
happened and the whole world flipped
upside down and everybody stayed at home
and they were just eating and basically
buying all of them so my rounds grew
like crazy that year all the restaurants
were closed you know everything like
that so yeah that helped us a lot uh so
yeah that helped tremendously and then I
told her I said when we bought
um our house I said well if you go and
you make like extra couple hundred every
week you know that's enough to do a
double payments every month keep
hammering on it and so we did and she
kept working and working and Benedict
did instacart for a little bit worked at
Chick-fil-A a little bit okay and uh
worked at a church doing Ministry for a
little bit so whatever it takes huh
right and now you're a hundred percent
free so I'm making 100 to over 200 at
some point in the high point right yeah
yeah good for you guys well done very
well done how's it free to how's it feel
to be completely free amazing yeah yeah
um I just I think of like everything
going on in the world and just it's
crazy from time to time
we sit there and I'm like well whatever
happens if we go in a recession it
doesn't really matter because we're debt
free we don't have to worry about those
burdens and payments and yeah so it's
very exciting another big goal was
before our daughter came I want to be a
girl
um and we were just like yeah we really
want to do this before we start having
kids and um we tried for a little bit
before we got her
um and so the fact that we could do this
before even had any kids was a really
big goal so yeah it's super cool that's
amazing I love the fact that uh I kept
telling her over and over I said we work
really hard for like two or three years
we can just bust our butts and pay
everything off and I kept saying live
like no one else just like your science
level
I walked in I was like oh my gosh it
literally I'm like
[Music]
yeah I mean at times it was like uh but
I'm like it's worth it it's worth it oh
yeah
you got two in a short period of time
that's amazing yeah I mean there was
that one point we were paying almost
half our income in just paying off our
our my route payment our mortgage and
then after we paid that off uh our route
in June I said let's just Hammer look
all out on this thing we were dropping
like 10 grand a month in to the house
and just just destroyed it I mean more
if we could at a time but yeah a few
thousand at least yeah so what would you
tell people is the key
uh determination well God is everything
God is the center of that we were
dedicated to glorifying him with our
money and and then just yeah keeping the
perspective of big picture and seeing
everything and I would say also little
sacrifices at times like times we would
tell our family we can't go out to eat
stuff like that like can't go with
friends to do stuff but we had the end
goal in mind so just keeping that stuff
in mind as well how old are you two I
just turned 30. I literally told her I
said I want to pay my everything off by
the time I'm 30. I turn 30 in beginning
November November 2nd and 27. ah very
cool yeah what's the house worth
we bought it for 115 and we did a bunch
of fixing up on that too
um I don't really I don't even know what
anything's worth I'm guessing maybe 150
maybe more
a little ranch it's a little ranch house
on 1200 square foot that's 100 paid for
an extra 100 yours yep that's pretty
cool very few people have that
experience in their life yep yep and you
guys did it by the time you were 30.
yeah we got a 15-year loan when we did
it I was like well if we can pay this
off in like five years and then I was
like forget that I was doing two no no
so take us home yeah so take it on take
us back a little bit have you all always
been good with money or what really
clicked that made you go no not me I
know when we got married so he's always
been good yeah I mean I've always been a
hard worker I
um saved money and my hope you know my
whole family's like that my brothers and
my parents and all that and that's just
the way we grew up and then we got
married and she was kind of like what
this is not how I live with money and
that's how I was taught it's like no
this is not the way we're gonna live
we're gonna do it this way and I'm so
glad I learned because he's so right
way to go you guys yeah we're proud of
you yeah thank you who were your biggest
cheerleaders back home
mm-hmm
[Music]
and my brother actually at the end of it
when we were trying to pay off our house
and finish our house off my brother has
this night around he bought this thing
like a year ago two years ago I don't
even know what it was and he was like
I'm gonna pay mine off before you pay
your house off and he actually did and
he did but I was like who cares we paid
it all off so good competition oh
they're so competitive oh my gosh and
then my other brother him and his wife
um they had uh student loans I got from
school and they paid off 57 000 in like
seven months or 15. yeah there's a lot
so the whole whole family's on oh yeah
yeah we're just we watch all your guys's
like your videos and we actually started
uh doing I did a Bible study we were
leading the Bible study and we were
doing uh right now media Bible study and
it was one of your financial Bible
studies was on there I don't even know
which one it was but and that was all
the principles and I was like teaching
it and I was like well I might as well
go along with this and learn this and
actually do it you know not just teach
it and but actually live it out so yep
yeah that was pretty awesome so yeah my
might have been the one we put on
YouVersion yes with the YouVersion Bible
app that might be yeah very cool good
for you guys thank you very good stuff
proud of you proud of you we got a copy
of the live and give bundle for you
that's The Total Money Makeover book The
Baby Steps millionaires book you're
going to be there before you know it and
of course a one-year membership to
Financial Peace University any of that
you don't need obviously give it away
and Inspire someone else like your whole
life has been an inspiration to other
people very very well done and today
you've been an inspiration of the people
very cool so excellent excellent job
good good work Corey and Kimberly
Sandusky Ohio 270
000 paid off in 36 months making 100 to
200 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's how it's done
that's the opposite of being 28 and
overwhelmed by ten thousand dollars
worth of debt
an earlier call isn't it interesting the
math and the math and the attitude
and how you just say I'm gonna kill that
I'm getting into that or this is killing
me
whether you're on top of it or it's on
top of you and it is a
it is the old Henry Ford quote
oftentimes if you think you can or you
think you can't you're right hope
belief that it can be done if you go do
the steps is actually more powerful than
the math yeah it really is we see it
we've seen it for 30 years we've seen it
over and over and over and over again
beautiful couple beautiful couple and I
just love how their story highlights the
importance of community that competition
that family competition that's so cool
and so good y'all drove each other to do
what was best for each of your
individual situations and that's just
that's awesome oh yeah they're driving
each other crazy in a good way
good stuff this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
our scripture today is Psalm 16 11 you
make known to me the path of life in
your presence there is fullness of joy
at your right hand our Pleasures
forevermore
Eleanor Roosevelt said do not stop
thinking of life as an adventure
you have no security unless you can live
bravely
excitingly
imaginatively unless you can choose a
challenge instead of competence
love it good love it get after it get
after it change something when in doubt
bust something what in doubt change
something and most people just live
quiet desperation as they say lives of
quiet desperation this idea of I'm
searching for stability I'm I'm
searching for calm nah
get it get after it Chris is with us
Chris is in St Louis hi Chris welcome to
the Ramsey Show
hey guys thanks for taking my call
um
first thing I think I need to give all
the callers a little one of their guys
if there's ever a debt free screen right
before you you do not need to hold the
phone up to your ear
[Laughter]
my right ear might be bleeding but uh
pretty awesome but
I got I wanted a question
um I'm just kind of curious my wife and
I we're in four five and six I feel like
we're doing a great job we're kind of
killing it I feel like um but I don't
know we I guess we did our emergency
fund and set off our life insurance
about five or six years ago uh since
then our debt has drastically gone down
we only have the mortgage obviously
um in our income has like doubled so
with having fewer payments like that's
for instance our six-month emergency
fund if you take all of our expenses
it's about fifteen thousand
um we make a little over 200 now so I
feel like
it's not a good ratio but I mean it is
our six months it's not a ratio to your
income because you're so it's an
interesting thing because what's
happening is that what used to be an
emergency
when you were broke you now cash flow it
oh well that's true yeah because you're
in you know you blow out a tire
you just go buy a tire
you don't have to hit the emergency fund
but when you're broke you're like oh god
oh no you know and you have you have
this drama and you go hit the emergency
fund right because you got no money but
you're making such good money you're
cash flowing a lot of bumps on the road
a lot of minor unexpected events that
would be when you're broke qualified as
an emergency so that's the reason we use
a ratio of expenses not a ratio of
income
I see okay
um yeah it just seemed like a small
amount compared to our income but like
you said if if we can catch well 90 of
everything it doesn't yeah and you've
got you've got a great income and you've
got other money I mean you got money
going into retirement seriously and
we're not going to cash that out for an
emergency but before you would get
foreclosed on you would
right okay well that makes sense
um and then another kind of on the same
lines
um we set up a life insurance at that
whenever we were both making you know we
were making like a hundred total so
right now which we're I guess five years
into the the 20-year term we have 500 on
each of us
while my wife makes like 80 I make 120
so I mean we need to how old are you
guys uh we're 35 both of us healthy
all right overweight
no smoke
nope wow another another 500 of 15-year
level term won't cost you anything
hardly
all right yeah go to xanderinsurance.com
and quote it and you'll be going it's
it's cost of a dead gun Pizza
right and so I'm gonna add another 500
just for the fun of it I mean you can
split it up however you want to but
um
it's not that she has to have 120 if you
die income replacement
but it doesn't cost that much to provide
that
okay yeah
again as a percentage of 200 000 what
you're going to spend on this policy is
almost nothing
doesn't really matter
I guess I'm talking about expenses again
because like we should have our house
paid off in like a year
um yeah this is more this is almost in
the area of luxury it's not necessarily
in the area of necessity okay but the
idea is if you die how do you want to
leave your wife
I want to leave her making 120 000 a
year off of Investments because it
didn't cost me anything but the cost of
a pizza to do that
all right
that makes sense but does she have to
have that to live oh my God no no I mean
she could live on half that easy if she
could make it yeah you got a half a
million on you should be just fine she
had 50 000 coming in plus her 80. you
know she'd have a hundred and something
thousand dollars coming in she'd be just
fine you know with that if you don't up
it but when you price it you're gonna go
it's a non-issue
okay well yeah yeah we were just kind of
looking over the big picture and I'm
like man I feel like
our life insurance and our emergency
fund are just very small now compared to
what we're making now but it is um it is
and it gets smaller over as you're the
other thing you're going to look up one
day and you're going to go I got a
million dollars or a million and a half
in my 401k
and then you're gonna go I probably
don't need any insurance now she's going
to be just fine
if I die and you get to the point the
insurance you don't need because you're
out of debt and you've so you become
self-insured with financial planning
yeah I think it's so cool these are the
fun Financial conversations to have
these are the conversations you have in
four five and six so for all of you who
are feeling frustrated in baby step two
having conversations about the debt
snowball someday you get to have
conversations you know about should I up
the emergency fund because my income is
so high and you know just talking about
killing it in four five and six I think
it's inspiring to hear you guys at this
point having these conversations because
this is a time where you can feel Joy
when talking about your finances yeah I
mean what's the next step for them the
next step is they're in seven yeah it's
about a year away paid off their house
okay the house just paid off now they
got almost zero expenses they got zero
debt okay then we start looking at
what's it take her to live what's it
take him to live in the event of a death
it's almost it's diminished greatly once
it take to
operate our household expenses to
emergency fund 15 000 is a lot then
laying around I mean you could have 20
or 30 if you want to but it's just
the the weird thing is is uh we share
and I talked about it a lot it was like
when we finally got a fully funded
emergency fund and we were finally out
of debt everything but the house
we almost quit having emergencies
[Music]
but it seemed like everything was an
emergency before that everything I mean
I we we live in a new construction
neighborhood and uh Sharon picked up a
nail in the front of her Tire this week
and so I get to I got to buy a tire
yesterday
um
but it was kind of a yawn yeah not a big
deal it perfectly feels different
whenever you have the cash to pay for it
oh that's inconvenient um you know oops
Yeah Yeah you know it's like uh instead
of an emergency it's an inconvenience
and that's not being snobbish and saying
I have money and so I don't no but the
point is you get this margin in your
life and it also gives you Financial
Peace emotional margin it gives you a
relational margin you know um
someone in our marriage that is not me
hit the garage side of the garage with a
car and left a dent in it the other day
and it wasn't me I don't know which of
the other people it was but I won't say
but it's like oh well we get to fix the
car oh well and it's like I don't have
to throw a fit because my wife dinged up
the car right well you were telling a
caller earlier that we
that was a Sprint
time when you're in baby step two and
you feel like you're drowning you feel
stressed out you got to get gazelle
intense and take six jobs like this is a
Sprint this isn't forever eventually you
will be through this hopefully you'll up
your income permanently and then these
things will not feel as big you're going
to get Chris Chris is right on the uh
Tipping Point he's he's almost tipped on
over so this question is really good
questions
and they're really natural questions
that you have to you kind of have to
intellectually make a shift once you get
away from desperation
and into margin away from you know drama
and into yawn and you kind of have to
make a shift and go okay what's wise now
what's wise now what's wise now and it's
less and less and less and less and less
and you know we used to joke I noticed
the other day my final life insurance
policy lapsed the other day and I hadn't
canceled them I could have canceled them
and saved the money uh but uh obviously
I mean we've got hundreds of millions of
dollars of real estate paid for Sharon
doesn't need any life insurance it was
ludicrous that I still had life
insurance in place but I just let it run
because she wanted it swi Sharon Watson
and she said I'd rather have that than
another you know Shiny Rock I'm like
okay you're gonna have it I'll keep it
it it's absolutely not a financial
planning thing it's a sharing thing you
know but it was irrelevant it's a yawn
at that point because the margin is
there that's what you're working towards
that's where we want to take you so very
very cool stuff that puts this hour the
Ramsay show in the books we'll be back
with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
have you been inspired to make a change
with your money want to know where to
start take our three-minute money quiz
to get a plan you can follow go to
ramseysolutions.com and search for get
started to get a plan for your money